crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab fish I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though
all right let's uh past our JUCO
above-ground cool goes better than most
Jane Austen self-diagnose go down low
this week last week here we don't forget
the crab feast
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
nother Tuesday the crab fees without an
awful quiet over there jailers I mean
you know it guys may not know this put
your boy Jay Larson had to take him to
the ER the other night he officially has
the look of a man who's been punched in
the face mm-hmm
what a tooth did that tooth sure did I
got some crazy infection y'all the
painkillers they gave me painkillers
didn't even work I mean didn't even work
at work at all these are the same
painkillers they gave my wife for when
she had a c-section had a human took it
I think this is what's gonna work for
you I try and not no dice and then we
went to the ER on Friday night two
people died and next to us I sat through
a play with level eight nine in my mouth
and then got home took another
painkiller nothing went to the ER with
you
waited there till 3:30 in the morning we
got that you got midnight 12:30 we got
there at 10:30 and I went up to the guys
I'm like listen guys I'm in like an
eight nine in pain I'm like all's I need
is a shot like give me a hit of morphine
that's all Mike if that's what my end
and Dantas whatever you call him told me
to do he's like I'm like Lourdes and
they go we don't have beds for you I'm
like I don't need a bed you can just do
in the hall sit over there in that group
of people over there all right night all
those people they're like I go you can
just do it in the hallway they go we
can't do that legally I'm like all right
so two hours like 1:30 I go up again I
go guys I'm dying I'm like all's I need
is a shot like this isn't a big deal
they're like it doesn't we don't have
the beds up I'm like all right whatever
3:30 they like they bring me in get they
give guess who they give me the shot in
the hallway in the hallway I told you
and I started laughing like you're real
what's happening
that's triage behind those doors well
it's good to have you it's good as we
approach the holiday with all of you all
feast our nation as always Jay Larson
comedy comm Jay Larson comedy on all
social media we have a bunch of dates
together coming up which we'll get to in
a minute for me personally I am going to
be at the La Jolla comedy
store next week the 18th and 19th
headlining over there la jolla so get on
out and then in January the 30th I'm in
Honolulu I'll give you more specifics
when it gets closer to it but if you if
you live out there you have a chance the
rest of you I mean I don't know if
you're gonna plan to get there but let's
talk about our dates sickle-cell you
give what you got to give Ryan Sickler
on Twitter Instagram and Facebook and
Ryan Sickler official Ryan Sickler com
so next Tuesday December 15th we have a
live crab feast podcast the Hollywood
improv tickets are only 5 bucks
all right that's a great little room
over there at the improv we're doing it
in like the lounge that's right it's
gonna be sick if you haven't been to a
live podcast it's how much fun is it we
have so much so much fun Brits always
fun and yeah and Steve Byrne is our
guests doors open at 8:30 shows at 9:00
$5 tickets the other thing I'm very
excited I'm happy to be able to do this
I'm headlining Debray improv on December
26th and 27th three shows right after
Christmas I said earlier hang tight I
wanted to be able to see if I could do
this and I was able to tickets are going
to be free absolutely free you paid a
service charge if you use the code crab
CREB at checkout you're only paying the
service charge tickets are free come out
I'm gonna have some special guests with
me we'll have a good time and then Jay
and I will also be January 23rd at the
San Francisco sketch fest with a live
crab feast we have Erica Roberts and
upon anon Sharla
so we got some sick guests up there
which is gonna be ridiculous yeah and
then we bounce right back to LA on the
31st right for a live podcast at La riot
and we're gonna have Pete Holmes and
Baron von so yeah three great live
podcast we got coming up I'm pretty
stoked I am - I'm really excited I'll
also be with Macbeth in court
unfortunately Jay can't come with us
up to Seattle we're back at the High
Line on February 6th at Super Bowl Eve
come out hang out with us shows it's 7
o'clock so you can get out there early
hang out with us for a couple hours and
then get home decent time tickets for
all shows were on Ryan Sickler calm and
the crab feast calm get your Christmas
merch today all orders do include free
domestic shipping in a flat $10
international fee get your Christmas
shopping done on Amazon help us out help
yourself
premium apps you know they're a buck
ninety-nine Facebook Fanpage iTunes all
like it's the world on Google Play now
and make sure you follow all things
comment on Instagram they'll be
promoting our shows back again touch of
modern calm let me tell you what's been
great for me about touch of modern I'm
just hitting up my Christmas gifts right
off it because if there are people in
your life do you like I don't know what
to get them go and touch your mom calm
you will find something cool whether
it's like dope speakers for your laptop
or cool home decor for your on cousin
sent me a real lightsaber real lifesaver
feel like to have [ __ ] like that they do
they have like the craziest cool stuff
gear and gizmos galore have someone on
your list that is totally into watches
this is the thing they have so many
random things on here but then they
always they have vintage watches how
often are you finding like a mass comm
that has vintage one I mean it's like I
don't even know about watches like you
and Kevin Christie and I've seen some
watches on there that have blown me away
well I mean doesn't say no you way you
know I'm saying touch your mind come go
there now and sign up so you don't miss
out I mean we've said this before all
these deals to they it's not like
they're going for weeks at a time
they're up for like two days and then
they're done so you don't get on that
Indiglo don't be sitting on that Timex
Indiglo nails literally launching every
day touch' Martin comm is the only
website to find gifts for everyone on
your list all the while offering the
best price on the web right now our
listeners can get immediate access when
they sign up a touch of modern calm
that's touch Aman calm do today you
don't want to miss the perfect gift and
excited to have tipsy elves back again
here these guys were on Shark Tank a
couple weeks ago and everyone wants
their crazy Christmas sweaters I got I
went on the website and I just I made me
laugh out loud some of the stuff they
have I got uh I got Santa peeing Merry
Christmas in the snow would you what was
one you got I got Santa on a unicorn yes
thank you to court they have collegiate
stuff as well but the Christmas stuff is
pretty crazy if you're going to one of
those parties you know I like my sweater
is it's not itchy it's not one of those
like big you know chunky itchy sweaters
yeah and it's not it's not skin tight
either it's not like Banana Republic you
got a little room in there do you put
soap holiday cookies my team steals I'm
thinking one way up their sweaters are
like nothing you've seen before
some not for the faint of heart that is
the truth while you're shopping for your
sweater check out the other holiday
include you could tire for yourself or
as a gift they have adult onesies also
little onesies and these are not stuff
that they found that Goodwill stores and
stuff like that these are brand new
sweaters these are not worn before you
know and you can get your size that's
what's really cool about it so right now
our listeners will get 20% off tipsy
elves calm on anything you order on the
site go do it now so you have the best
selection to choose from and have it in
time for your ugly Christmas sweater
party go to tipsy elves calm enter our
code crab CRA be at checkout and get 20%
site-wide discount that's pretty pretty
damn good deal there that's tipsy elves
calm our code crab a lot of special
things on the crab feast this week we
announced the mall this one this guest
is no exception
super stoked to have him back on because
he is just he's one of the funnest
people we know in comedy please welcome
finally Brooke got a bag you dudes bro
over the social webs bro yeah Guignol
bra about your people and our people
we're sorry it took so long but we're
glad you're back you guys been out there
pumping out some Oh spring huh mm-hmm
yeah we do know it there's three
combined now frickin grow and come dead
well before we get into more of your
witty banter will you please tell
everybody whatever you want them to know
about theof them where they can find you
all that stuff yeah dude oh you can find
me on that ass Brad
no I'm joking dude you can find me um in
Boston at laughs comedy club
December 18th and 19th of this year so
this exciting current I hope you
wouldn't be promoting 2016 and in
January at the Pittsburgh improv this
January seventh eighth ninth and tenth
and Twitter website on Twitter at do
Vaughn th EO vo in and then have a
special coming out on Netflix in
February or March called no offense love
it and your podcast my podcast is called
the allegedly podcast if you like
Hollywood and stuff like that and just
like stories from you know weird
celebrities and comedians uh different
than these guys it's a more like
celebrity-driven is called allegedly you
can find it on iTunes see how we did
that see what he did there that's
different than these guys
it's celebrity but no this is more humor
[ __ ] this is more humor drivel if you
like this it's IDO you know this is
funny
well I Congrats when you're special by
the way they smell and that's what
something we were talking about before
we started about so you went back to
your hometown you're from a small town
outside of New Orleans yeah a small town
outside of New Orleans called Covington
Louisiana and our towns the most famous
actually Lee Harvey Oswald went to our
middle school yeah what do you do six
seven eight man l swear dude I think in
rush hour middle school what was your
mascot yeah we are mascot for a low
walls called the young Gunners and then
no but all the fans just like a wave
that's hilarious oh man I can't believe
that we are middle school Pistol Pete
Maravich lived and died not a lot of gun
and lot of gun in there he listened to
died in our town man he lived in our
country the Covington coming to
Louisiana dude Oh rich tan too late unit
Tulane University had there a primate
testing facility Center in our town
that's where most people worked at
actually crime I'm a test you mean like
animal testing yeah really yeah we mean
testing testing test animal testing bro
you know whatever they put uh but in
1994 seventy infected monkeys got out
way hold on a minute
seventy god I'll have you know this is
the second time they get out while I was
growing up
that's what's that [ __ ] movie where
the chimps coming and the family ate no
right at beginning what is Aaron playing
the Apes now it's not playing cage they
come later
these gremlins okay that's it 28 days
wasn't that all chimpanzees or something
like that the candle all that that's
like coming uh hold on a second so you
want something on you 14 stories not a
YMCA summer camp I remember the police
came to summer camp and your Hawaiian
don't rip a [ __ ] adult you go.you oh
yeah we [ __ ] I remember surrounding a
couple chimps outside of it this is real
I'm not joking I remember us around a
couple chips outside of a kenny rogers
roaster didn't rank them we didn't touch
him somebody respected i think somebody
shot one with a dart and then somebody
shot just killed one somebody good
neighbor came out well I mean generally
I mean there was a lot of people out
there lot of guns we are they coulda did
uh wait why'd they come to they couldn't
find anyone else that came to summer
came like we need to get some people
they needed the older they just needed I
guess you know they had a big group of
people I mean they probably had a
hundred something people out there they
needed as many as they could get you
know I mean it's unbelievable infected
with what you know they didn't tell us
it said infected what said it would come
on TV or papers and everything you can
still there's still a few cuz this was
before the Internet but there's still
like some some places you can find like
links to little articles and stuff and I
remember they interviewed one lady who
worked at like a service station near
the closest place to where they'd gotten
loose mm-hmm and uh one came it was
pumping gas full service here they're
like you see I see enough people
monkeying around here all the time
anyway this lady said but I thought that
was kind of cute but uh yeah man so it's
kind of cool cuz we shot this special
back in on New Orleans is about fifty
miles from our group so a lot of people
came out and you know from there and and
went to it which was really cool cuz it
was like you know for a lot of them and
that's why I wanted to do at home a lot
of my friends and stuff from home would
never even you
to see something like that you don't get
to be in that environment some people
not handle themselves this one lady came
out and was just cheering the whole time
dressed up Lee Ann LSU just cheering
yelling defense but she was just
cheering actually like inappropriately
like it their setups and no ideas just
cheered she wasn't drunk or anything
they threw at a plate he's blacked out
probably the wrong event yeah is not
that was wild man was that shot in New
Orleans like down close to Bourbons here
was like downtown about six blocks off a
Bourbon Street the oldest theater in
town they recently refurbished it a
couple other comedians have gone down
there Hannibal Buress just some shows
down there Ralphie did a show down there
I know cool um it was cool man it was a
cool spot that's awesome man it was good
it was a tough choice to like cuz you
decide where to do it you're like you
know it's just like picking to do any
kind of show where you gonna have people
come out you're like is this place gonna
be good I'd never perform there you guys
know it's like the first time you go to
a new comedy club like that first show
is kind of like how does the stage feel
you know like what does the audio feel
like you know can I look over this side
of the room I like to lean over here
we're a little light but yeah you know
what else I look at for the exits I
think it was I swear to god I think it
was Buddy Hackett that said that he
would he would just the only thing he
would think about when he finally got to
like just meta on stage was where those
fire exits were in case you okay some
apes got loose - shot two shows man nice
and they never caught it although say
they never caught all the primates
either they probably wait shut come on
oh yeah they never caught all of them
there's probably ten I think eight that
they didn't catch but there was also
like a lot of like I didn't trust
anybody's [ __ ] judgement in there if
you I couldn't get out I wouldn't try
anybody in that town account sixty-two
monkeys there's no [ __ ] way
somebody accurately counted 62 monkeys
to line them all up and said all right
you go right one two something they did
that they were hyper so maybe there are
[ __ ] Bigfoot's out there then and
it's these goddamned infected monkey was
alive was the second time in our home a
Bigfoot Covington in Louisiana
how'd they get that right Covington yes
somebody left something open some didn't
wanna go come on everybody a scream man
we just ate bananas you're [ __ ] 69
cents a pound on the outside you look at
here jugs I why do we evolved all we had
we had it dialed in so talking about
your hometown and where you grew up I
don't remember if I feel like we would
remember this and maybe I can't believe
we would overlook what you told us that
when you were born your dad was how old
but that was 70 my dad was born in 1910
and we didn't talk about this last I was
bill 1880 [ __ ] no your dad was just
crushed maybe but he was old he was
grown how was your mom used to say to me
I'm grown how old was your mom when she
had you 32 mole was 30 to 70 and 30 to
38 year difference were they married yep
they were married had four kids total so
I got two younger sisters that are two
and four years younger wait a minute
guys Wow seven seventy war he had a kid
yeah yeah yeah he holy [ __ ] have any for
you had a kid not a good idea you're out
there in your 73 and you're looking for
[ __ ] just [ __ ] just chill just jerk off
yeah dial it back it doesn't end well
for anyone
I'm a good boy turtle yeah he was
fertile man and he actually had a woman
that hit me up on Facebook or something
instead that
my dad was her dad a woman I'd never
even met before called him the salmon
it's called a bag yeah she's like 56 and
she looks just like my dad is it weird
and I don't want to tell her that
because a it's like weird a tall woman
she looks like a man if you don't know
her and then it turns out that say we're
not related for you get tested or
something this is like oh that's we just
look like a bobble he's like we have
your reports you're not related but we
got some phantom monkeys that you
definitely related to over here we got a
couple of your brothers behind door hop
cage number two is it because of
stand-up and everything she was able to
spot who you were and find you or I
don't know searching I talked to her on
the phone and uh oh you spoke to her I
spoke to her yeah Oh cuz it seemed weird
you know it's weird to me she kept she
hit you up skip hit sending me these
messages and I was like look how many
before you responded mm three she was
like look all gasp anyway so that's what
that was almost weird but now it's kind
of crazy because if I see like a
four-year-old I'm not a pedophile I'm
thinking about the future you know what
I'm saying I'm like it is this girl
marriage material you know for you yeah
think about it that way you know raizy
so but wait um wait so do you keep in
touch with this woman um no she does she
uh we had a little bit of a falling out
we never met we had a falling out why
you just like listen I'm just not down
what's her name her name is Michelle
so don't say that I mean but in it she
might be my half-sister you know she
also might be here bring that monkey
girl the mother that was a chicken what
uh
it was weird man how did you have a
falling out over I mean
I can't remember what happened oh she
just kept bringing up [ __ ] like oh she
said that my dad knew she existed but
never came okay so she was pissed that
she he claimed you for but not yet your
of you right yeah with your mom yeah but
it's almost like my dad wouldn't do that
that's what I that's what I said I said
the man I know wouldn't do that like he
might [ __ ] father four kids in his
70s six a rolling out on them that's
right so I guess there's like and part
of me I guess maybe doesn't want to
investigate cuz I don't want to know you
know it's like you know you you think
your dad and a person in a perception
you know yeah so we'll see man you know
I plan to get to the bottom of it when I
have a little more free time yeah you
know that's crazy
did he did you know of any other
families he had before you yet another
family yeah I mean I've married before
60s and almost 70 yeah when he claimed
that so this one if claiming like it's
like your shoes a roller well these days
yeah you got a really like I don't know
you know you got I don't know man you
know I was planning to sit down so she
also said she had a brain aneurysm at
one point so that maybe I don't know
what a brain aneurysm is but I know it
has to do with your brain yeah a maybe
think with what does that mean did your
brain blow up and you just you know
working on fragments like I don't know
who this like you know you some of
Google and I'm a chat with her you know
that's our core I mean that's good you
keep in touch with the half-sisters from
the other family know a little bit it's
vague though I mean what do you think
almond with a 60 year old right yeah
nothing so the hands just another thing
to feel bad about when I'm at home later
so is your dad passed yeah he'd be uh
he'd be like a hundred and six I guess
oh that old really sixteen so thirty
years ago how old was he when he was 86
what was that like having like being
like 14 and everyone else's dads are
like thirty and your dad's like crush
than 80 uh as he is a gainers and all
that yeah he totally
the armored weekend or a basketball game
fell asleep in the stand they're asleep
and all the kids would make fun of it
like y'all suck man that is weird
but you guys were tight I mean I think
we were pretty tight it was just weird
cuz I was just getting to the point
where you kind of get to know your dad I
feel like you know yeah so it was weird
you know it's just weird growing up with
an old dad he was cool though like he
was as young as you could be for a man
that old you know like I mean he still
worked like he used to do he was the
dude if you at colleges who would like
barked out to people and get him to sign
up for credit cards and share alike he
didn't have any money like usually like
you have an old dad he has money like
like that's one thing about my mom like
if she gives me advice I'm like you who
you [ __ ] some old yeah you are not
giving advice you know [ __ ] out myself
you know but he was a dude at college
that would like get people to come over
and sign up for credit cards so I
remember he used to let me as soon as I
was tall if he would let me drive him to
these colleges brought like 60 80 miles
bro
I remember being ten or 11 probably 11
years old driving dude driving driving
on the interstate bro said come on 80 in
his town you could drive you a 10 or a
month or your dad was 70 plus exact not
10 but 11 I definitely when we're
driving at 11 it's great definite when
we're driving at 12 yeah it was a matter
of height [ __ ] I grew taller early I hit
like five ten and driving those college
kids credit out of the gate they're like
no no one like ridiculous [ __ ] give away
t-shirts yeah corn who need this cool
sort is that a real your dad was he
sounds like a trendsetter to me it was
trend well I'm not a trendsetter but
like what do you call once it's like
painting with trailblaze traveling man
where did you apply for that job like
dude how old do things like trust me I
got that I got an 11 year old son
I got an 11 year old valet did over what
time I dropped it with the post office
in an ebony parking right yeah she's
like just dropped me here come back what
are you driving
Cutlass 88 wasn't you know like coffin
to all that nice velvet interior at that
during those times they called it a
Negro mobile you know what I'm saying
down in Covington oh yeah yes what they
called it man and it [ __ ] was and he
bought it off you know a couple of
brothers dude had to [ __ ] like 12s in
the [ __ ] trunk so it was like real oh
and they were a horrible sound and
soonest
tweeters all blown out rattled bro rad
all right so I remember had a bunch of
[ __ ] uh what did he spell in there
let me think it's a Chinese food he told
[ __ ] Chinese food in this 12 but I
remember I dropped them at the post
office yeah now circle the block I must
have hit 11 cars [ __ ] going around
this block and it's called the piece of
[ __ ] like banging drilled him just
sideswiped them because I couldn't the
steering wheel was loose you know it was
that first power steering man we just
touched it that [ __ ] would never glide
like three lanes like Jesus Christ you
could feel it this worm and to get it
straight yeah I remember that we had a
station wagon or that [ __ ]
12 hit parks Club last night dude I must
have hit I swear to God I hit 6 cars
going around that block and no one
caught you or anything you just get back
in New Orleans dude they didn't care
they still ain't catching nobody yeah
you're right without that do you know
what other jobs your dad had like before
you was a writer he was a writer he was
a Polish Nicaraguan because I'm polish
Nicaraguan and uh oh yeah shortened ya
Vaughn kurnitz housekeys my full name
for real yeah that's your birth name and
you shortened it yeah I don't know why
say together is von kurowsky Theodor
Capitan Yvonne Carnot El Capitan he's
your middle name what's that family name
my mom my mom's mom so I say I like like
a falling out with her family [ __ ] I
don't know did you say people were
[ __ ] in the family
people were [ __ ] T where I'm falling
outs people was doing it all but we did
it man who was [ __ ] I don't know no
money well no nobody that I knew man
wait so what shower together but nothing
got so they said we did it save water
you were telling us about your mom's
brother it was your mom's brothers these
uncles that are dead no my dad's
brothers all dead okay so were they
close to age yeah it was a little
younger I think you know actually one of
them was older when we got hit by car
and died went down in New Orleans
sure wasn't you yeah they died man I
mean I didn't know him he got hit by a
car I'm gonna hit my car was on a
bicycle oh that's terrible and uh and
how do you get hit by a car in the
[ __ ] 30s or whatever like them cars
you knew they were out right and how
many were there
in his defense of the bikes could have
been too great the worst slow-motion
death ever but you said there was
another one that died and the war like
the warhead no a guy throw them in the
Sharks I don't know what happened but
that's what they said I know they
weren't lying about it but you don't
know where he was no or how he got out
there like SeaWorld or something that he
fell off a boat and there were sharks
they saw Fox you got to assume he got
eaten by sharks I mean less he drowned
himself but would you falling off like a
like a like an aircraft care like a big
boat like a peak of p38 I mean it was
probably the 30s or 40s probably the 30s
or 40s maybe damn I don't know what were
they had then Korean maybe you said you
saw a guy get shot you thought I saw a
brother get shot man down by Mardi Gras
world you saw a guy gets shot mm-hmm
what who somebody shot him in the back
another black guy at Mardi Gras world
what is that it's like a place where
they sell the Mardi Gras stuff with the
beads and accoutrement say just what did
you see I mean saw two black dudes one
of them started walking away from the
other one you know arguing the bass to
walk away you caught it seemed like that
was probably arguing and did he die I
had the window up I don't know if he
died even stick around if we can find
out no dude I mean to be honest there's
so much crime in New Orleans it's
specifically black on black it just
seems dangerous to stick around you know
yeah even if it were white guy like I'm
not [ __ ] sticking around care who's
getting shot yeah I mean if it was a
chick with some [ __ ] tits maybe I'd
holler out the window like some do you
hold all through a tiny little crack
with the crime in your town growing up
too we didn't have a lot of crime man
everything was pretty chill we had some
PDF files I remember though I remember
one time we had a lot of PD files
actually I lived in this four-plex
and they had a lady at the end of his
date and she was a she was she worked as
a substitute teacher and she was dating
some student
it's really you know oh wow yeah it's
you know some older students and these
dudes were men though like these were 16
year old 17 year olds so she had the
kind of same situation dad was rolling
in yeah kind of but a little ology but
she was only like 32 or 30 yes she was
probably about 32 and she was uh but I'm
her one time one of these students is
over to me and this other dude was out
in this guy's car how are you at this
time I'm probably I was probably 11 okay
so I'm out in this dude's cauldron his
CB radio right here one of those CB
radios and we [ __ ] made up names you
know woodchuck and [ __ ] snuck into
this guy's car while he's in there well
they let they let us go out of his car
so that would keep us out of the house
and he could bang so they could bang out
you know we didn't really know that at
the time mmm but armored we got on a CB
radio and next thing you know we had
some trucker who driven off the
interstate to come and meet up with us
and he was a PDF file oh come on so it
was weird like catch a present yeah no
Lord oh man
cuz this dude like at the time it didn't
he it was chill you know this dude
showed up and he but like he actually
physically showed up drove yeah he drove
14 miles off the interstate you told him
where you guys were like joking the
whole time yeah we were just you know
mosey trip was he propositioning you at
the time or is he just like where here's
what I remember dude I remember we were
standing outside and he had a bunch of
tootsie rolls I actually Candace
remember down yeah I haven't had him in
years
but Blackbirds I would not I mean it and
I remember he's trying to get my buddy
to see how many tootsie rolls they can
put in his mouth that's what I remember
and a dude had about 15 of them in there
and I was trying to he was doing it yeah
he'd put one in and I put one in this
dude man and then this dude who was
inside came out and ran him off so oddly
enough we got you know kind of saved by
a victim the victim yeah so it really
all came full circle it was just a wild
neighborhood man it was just white trash
just you know and who did you hang with
like your dad was older did you
gravitate toward anyone elses that
eating friend's dad's or anything like
that yeah
Willian that lived across the street his
family was legit you know and they were
real Christian and he wants like a
private school and uh and so I would
kick it with him you know eventually
really we go and you were in a four-plex
yeah they had a house with like a gate
they had like graaah that a driveway
they had like she said that was really
they had like a you know they had like
normal [ __ ] you know but uh it was what
it was a weird place man it was a weird
weird place is your family still there
like where's your mom nope my family all
moved my brother and sister and I live
in Baton Rouge my wanna live in Baton
Rouge everybody moved to all different
states but everyone ended up in Baton
Rouge is about an hour and 20 minutes
where I'm from okay but it's good man
you know it's Louisiana dude and it was
the 80s and 90s they don't have that
anymore you know 80s and 90s or tootsie
rolls man yeah but I didn't have that
[ __ ] I do was put him in his mouth I did
I said was Wow crazy [ __ ] was he scares
the [ __ ] I think I didn't lure you with
candy I don't know what the game plan is
after he said let's take on a Florida
not kidnap you take it apart yeah and
you're like [ __ ] Disney World Oh
Florida dude you'd see you mean you'd
seen Florida written on t-shirt yeah
like in Florida Brett let's go you know
I mean it's just but they had and they
also had a lot of pedophiles in our area
because we live in this shitty
neighborhood we're not to dwell on
pedophilia well kind of files I think
they should all be like no yeah very
painted bright orange beef right arm had
a file but then a court you know god
forbid one of us goes down I'm pretty
sure we're safe yeah let me ask you this
growing up in that area you guys living
in the four Plex you have all this [ __ ]
going on how're you doing well in school
we do in school what were you doing yeah
I was doing well in school man I think I
just didn't spent most of my time by
myself really you know it's kind of a
little bit of a loner I guess I was like
ashamed of where we lived like it was
[ __ ] shitty it's nice to ride my bike
to school was like five miles so driving
catching the bus cuz I don't want to see
people see me get off you know poor
neighborhood bus and you're on eighty
six and a half you got to get off on
that [ __ ] Ray and a handicap ramp for
them fire merchants do that one kid in
our in our neighborhood who his dad was
a Elvis impersonator right I'm gonna
mall town like you don't work much you
know what I'm saying like if they only
have 11 under people in town nobody
needs the [ __ ] Elvis impersonators
yeah for what and he was really this a
drunk you know and he was hiding behind
the costume but around Christmas they'd
let him dress up like Santa the city
would pay him and he was a seasonal
grader he would [ __ ] greet people
they were like all right he could pull
Elvis all I'm sure but uh and he [ __ ]
I remember he made his son a wooden
shirt one time he made this boy Nathan
Brooke he made little Nathan a [ __ ]
wooden sure cause I remember holding
half of it up when they [ __ ] nailed
it better nail him into the shirt
there's a plywood shirt and slide it
over and I'll be on and he loves it it
was like the only thing his dad ever
made and probably her got him I remember
just [ __ ] crying I was [ __ ] tears
on top of the [ __ ] plywood
yes ply but it was wood and it was
sanded oh my god one time do you wear it
all the time but over the summer a
[ __ ] hornet's nest he kept it outside
that's what I remember what else it
could have it could have been him you
know rats but I think it was Hornets but
uh and we didn't draw swastikas on it
because we were ants [ __ ] we didn't
have we didn't know any Jews we just
seemed like drawings and [ __ ] at school
and pay
put some [ __ ] you know yeah I believe
you but uh but anyway man those are the
good old days dad and the bad old days
the wooden shirt man always shirt what
were you like we were alone in school
are you popular were you like funny
pretty funny I think it was the funny
kid I mean you guys were probably class
clowns huh I wasn't really here's the
thing I always thought I always knew I
was funnier than the class clown always
but you didn't say anything I mean among
my group and stuff I did not probably I
pulled a couple practical jokes on
teachers right but I let them have that
[ __ ] two minutes because I was like
thanks guys look at doing - man I'll do
10 right now I was always playing I was
in the class I mean I remember our class
plan he was a full blown clown I think
he was hilarious we loved them Sean
McIntyre is a cop in my hometown now he
is yeah and he was the funniest dude
alive he would just he'd do anything to
make everyone laugh and he we loved what
he would do it you know he was just so
funny I'm so I was always funny but I'd
pay to watch McIntyre just be Mack you
know cuz he was just hilarious
was he goofy like would he get up and go
yeah he would do whatever whatever you
need him to do yeah he would do it yeah
I didn't do that like I never got up I
was just saying I'm saying yeah I was a
talker from right back and got him words
yeah it was kind of made the girls laugh
I was just kind of a dick I didn't even
do that I just made this was kind of a
dick I remember a thing
and I remember I remember one time this
was my this is my one of my favorite
high school moments I may have talked
about in here before but do you guys
ever have a legit food fight in your
school cafeteria no this this I was
fortunate enough to be there I was I was
a junior so I was fortunate I was
accepted because this is one of these
things that you know I'm in school now
at this point three years and I'm all
and our cafeteria was pretty big it was
uh it was a three tier so they had this
level G then one goes a middle but they
weren't mega levels but they were still
big enough three tiers yeah you go boom
down a flight of stairs boom and then
the big bottom floor so the top two
weren't big but they were like little
offshoots of this big floor and down
there's where you got all the food and
[ __ ] okay but then they had this one
little store where you brought your own
money extra money you could buy ice
cream and all this extra [ __ ] cookies
that they didn't give you threw the
pizza line right is this where like
students would run it and stuff so that
like other stuff you could buy in there
I'm right Oreos and Nutter butters and
all that [ __ ] off to the side so it
kept there kept being a rumor
year after year there was gonna be a
food fight in this particular year it
was a strong [ __ ] room shit's going
down and everyone knew it everyone knew
it and we would do if I remember
correctly you had like ten periods or
whatever or eight and then lunch varied
for everyone from for period for which
is an early like nobody wants to eat
lunch at like 10:45 but that was the
earlier five or six yeah and then we had
a five and a six little later and I
think we were in the middle so one class
had come in had their lunch bell rings
and we go in and everyone knows about it
there's not a person and that lunch also
wasn't just 11th graders it was a
mixture when impression result though
well they have been going for we heard
about a food fight ninth grade and never
happened ten but what I'm saying is did
you guys know about this a couple days
in advance like PDF replicate be a bomb
fluff I'm pretty sure it was pizza
Friday yeah I do remember correctly and
it was it's going down and they had
milkshakes this is what I'll never
milkshake you could buy in that little
store okay so a guy named Mark I was
sitting in the table with him very much
like this if it was a full circle and
he's just looking at the death now he
wasn't there I don't know why we had a
death month I think it was mark I don't
know whatever seems like a deaf person
trying to say mark da this guy was he
had he had his hearing and he said
hearing mark blind is [ __ ] oh sorry
sorry sorry say and he was like it's
going down I'm like he's like I'm
starting it I don't give a [ __ ] one
starts it it'll never happen and he's
like this is what we're doing if you
don't want to be a part of it see you
later split the table but I'm gonna take
this milkshake and I'm just gonna throw
it over his head we were on the top
floor so he was just gonna chuck it back
and his goal was to throw it hard enough
that it would get to the bottom level
hit blow up scream food fight and people
would go apeshit like like movie star
leaps right 80s style oh yeah and he's
and he said here I go
and he's like it when we do it we are
flipping our table up and we're getting
behind it we are taking everything we
can and we're battle this is one that
folds yes exactly we're battling this
this [ __ ] level right here and I was
like I'm so [ __ ] in on it like I'll
have the balls to start it but if you
get this [ __ ] going I'll tell you
something corns coming after and he took
that [ __ ] milkshake and he threw it
up in the air and all of us just watch
it in slow motion and it hits the bottom
and he screams food fight we flipped
that table all three levels went balls
on the walls oh it was everywhere and
people were going nuts and the
principal's running through they were
hitting his ass they didn't give a [ __ ]
milk seven-year-old kids with blow it up
over the walls everywhere it was fan
[ __ ] it was so awesome and they Scott
on it they came and screamed I don't
know I want to say the guy might have
got a megaphone and [ __ ] shut it down
shut it down and then for the rest of
the year we had to have lunch in silence
it was silent lunch people would walk by
you'd hear them having their small
silent lunch for the whole three things
they shut that side room down it was
just what the school served there was no
milkshake five men it was phantom all
were ruined they were like we gotta
clean these wall it was [ __ ] awesome
it was awesome it was great did it look
really Gloria it look it did did you pop
up probably lasted a couple of minutes
sauce and you could pop up over and look
over at your you know table and look cuz
we were up top we the only table and
that had made like a wall of defense out
of their table yeah because I think I
said yeah I think everyone we get behind
it and stand up and throw them all the
way at the bottom like give me that
metal band going trying to hit like a
buddy all the way down there laughing
the whole way like there and there
wasn't it you know to be but it was
it was one of those things it was just
like you could taste it if he would have
never done that there would have
nautical girls running out of there
where they getting it now hell no
everyone got into that [ __ ] she's
jamming our silverware or not we are
going somewhere you know what I don't
remember if we have a [ __ ] knife
across that all right I feel like that's
like yeah please body food fight I'm
imagine if like seems dad had to come in
and talk to the principal ease asleep in
there should be like a man you just wake
up and your son hit him no it was it was
that was a pleasure to be a part of that
it was so awesome that is cool and they
couldn't just get I think I don't know
if they got him or not I think they did
cuz he threw that and they might have
suspended him a couple days but we had
to eat I mean you couldn't even that was
I want to say there was a teacher on
every level like you couldn't even go
like it was silent but they were pizza
dude did they get anyone did you
they get your boy first I think they got
marked for start I can't I know he got
in trouble but I can't remember what
happened he loves me Wow yeah like then
I hate about being an adult is like you
can't just do [ __ ] like that no no yeah
you were right weren't sure to do that
but didn't you like it was rebellious
and it was like just that energy of all
we're gonna do today's the day [ __ ]
and I mean you've just seen it all fly
back and forth it was criticized if
we're looking at each other like holy
[ __ ]
underline 11 times yeah
chocolate milkshake and a standard
Styrofoam cup I will never forget it he
just took it and threw it over his head
and man as soon as that [ __ ] thing
hit it was Apes you guys have to go
through the rest it was his fetid monkey
Oh ever had to go through oh yeah they
weren't ever gonna let us out for that
but that was their next thing was come
back here on Monday and watch what the
[ __ ] happens and it was all that room
was shut that like you know they you
know like when the mall closed
Changez down who cleaned it up I don't
think I don't I mean we had to clean up
the big [ __ ] like trays and all that
[ __ ] that were there because people are
frizz being plates like they were doing
whatever they could you know that [ __ ]
was right do you remember I don't know I
got shanked one guy took a beat to the
neck do we forget my concrete wait did
you at a college and did you go to
college yeah
with LSU into University Arizona until
bunch of different schools why 107
schools total well I think we talked
about that for a four-year degree yeah I
got extra credits almost have something
else like a master's I didn't know you
take different classes right Sol's
bounced around is taking the same
classes and finally a what do you mean
this dudes like 101 all over the POE
yeah I would take speech speech
everywhere speech class speech class and
never 101 102 yeah threes cuz I dude
you've been taking these elect you
dissed you know you ain't getting it you
know finally they got me Ryan should be
a math mother finally they got me right
then I'm an urban planner actually is
what I am legally yeah parsers at four
cities or whatever what are you ill
never you want to make the urban
whatever you want to get that's your
tech hire your technical for flex on
some Nelly son and it's all I'm an urban
planner
oh you throw some Nelly on anything ZURB
LSU Arizona World University New Orleans
Santa Monica College College of
Charleston semester at sea
she's like a floating University we get
that title and then won one of the
oceans they were loyal of New Orleans
loyal at private school Christian
Christian faiis why were you failing out
around she may be honest I don't know
what was going on man I was popping
around you know we time yeah was a
different time
but you were adventurous like that just
driving around my god just enroll in
school here we just get jobs what would
you do people were young yeah yeah you
lived on campus or whatever yep live on
campus met some dudes one time would you
live in dorms and stuff mmm no I did a
job so it live off-campus unless y'all
lived in the dorms oh yeah that [ __ ] was
dope yes that grades we used to pee
under this dudes door every night
this [ __ ] neighbor and he never said
a word I think he liked guys pissing in
my door up throwing that door with my
robe on and getting that you never said
no rollcall I will in college I would
have a tiger bro purple oh yeah dude
yeah that's what I want LSU man they
used to pay me to play uh to write
papers for the basketball team man when
I went to school there
yeah one of the assistant coaches used
to meet me in the lock and the student
mute and they Sports Museum
I heard you two got to come talk to it
about speeches yeah man is do it come
give me cash give me tickets for like
different events real autograph yeah I
had a bunch of autograph like Shaquille
O'Neal [ __ ] stroll mile Swift's was
there I remember him and listen whiter
out of 15 to throw thanks man
I'll meet you out I don't have a good
crossover but I can hide 15 Twitter so
did you know who you were writing for
specifically you did yeah and how'd you
get how'd you get that gig one of my
friends tutored these guys for like this
university and and I was gonna write and
the assistant coach would meet me and
pay me that was the best part so you
would write how many papers let's say
I'm in total I probably wrote about five
papers you know come a page 15 there's a
lot of [ __ ] yeah so you were doing what
was probably a good portion of their
grade was this paper so hold on a second
you ever thought he might not just have
a masters he could have a doc
that's a good point oh my god you know
who'd you write for oh you can say I'm
trying to think they had just some
basketball players they had man I don't
think anybody that one guy that maybe
maybe went pro for a little bit that was
it
did you ever [ __ ] up do they all get
good grades I told them they weren't
getting aids that's all yeah [ __ ] that
kept trades for yourself spread these
days around seven colleges that can't be
drawn Mars 120 bucks that's it for 52
and like get like I had a brother that
was in like a rehab facility I would get
him and all of his friends fright
front-row tickets to the basketball game
so you'd see him at the next game like
all these [ __ ] a a ditch and a
scratch and what the fiends she was deaf
marking the game so we had a definite
move to our town actually what was that
kid's name beat him up they beat him up
they thought he was doing magic and they
beat him home he was always doing like
all his hands yeah I get that's called
silent Lu I'm not doing magic with a
whole family beat his ass no dogs no
quarters where's the dogs [ __ ]
nah man they beat his ass dude like
that's terrible as Lance it was terrible
man I remember right and help me in the
rocks he were to help me with a stick in
the rocks like I don't [ __ ] it man I
ain't doing nothing you like Ben I would
with his 60 apes chasing me down man if
they stopped beating you they sword B
scream maybe you should take that stick
and swing it instead of right now help
me mother and I'll say this man he was
the most handsome deaf kid I've ever met
in my life the kid very beautiful it was
beautiful yeah all right hold on a
second so after LSU then you went to
Arizona we just driving around how long
did you go to LSU honey I went on and I
actually went on it I'll tell us you
twice
and then you just want to get out of
town what were you do I went out of town
first University Arizona okay yes that's
where I started then came back to LSU
they went every colleges Charleston they
went to Loyola Charleston South Carolina
yeah that was that that's a good town is
awesome yeah a little slavey but
otherwise awesome it kind of has this
kind of slavish black backdrop but
awesome awesome town yeah yeah
I mean it's like an old mutt like a lot
of old money white traditionalist kind
of [ __ ] yeah you can get past that
[ __ ] you know yeah I hear that it's cool
a lot of hippies and [ __ ] running around
you know a lot of people eat and [ __ ]
they've grown you know that [ __ ]
tastes like [ __ ] were you getting
student loans what were you doing we
just paying your student loans bro
student loans like you can bargain have
a blast will you get in like a deal
because your dad was Hawking credit uh
yeah I said I got a reverse mortgage on
that Cutlass son you should have been
teaching the [ __ ] driving course the
goddamn school you've been doing you're
already a veteran by the time you got in
there oh yeah man those are the good old
days man some would say we could just
stay young is this where you is in
college where you saw this happen
I was so much in the frisbee it's my
buddy Timmy dude so where Pittsburgh
dude you know no offense this is not my
college but I know this is adulthood man
and uh and this cop stop this dude and
my buddy had to [ __ ] so bad right and uh
the cops you guys driving oh no here's
what happened my buddy [ __ ] in the back
of his car on top of his frisbee right
in the you know the heart on the red
side parked right yeah get a [ __ ] so bad
right and uh and I was like [ __ ] man and
I couldn't get all the carcasses we're
in a tunnel he literally stopped in a
tunnel and I think he did it on purpose
you know cuz you knew I couldn't get out
so I'm stuck in the car and he [ __ ] in
the back seat dude knit it where is he
peeing right huh Rizzy peeing he ain't
peeny [ __ ] there's no way you should be
without he coulda peed into a sweatshirt
but then a cop pulls up and I'm like
[ __ ] dog this [ __ ] ain't gonna go over
well
magic magic the cop brought a cop
[ __ ] first he comes and looks in at
him dude uh first he comes in he like
looks in the window right and he's like
who's driving and I was like you know
guys nobody's in the driver's seat right
I was like my buddy and my buddy is a
[ __ ] and he's be a mascot for the
Pittsburgh Pirates and stuff like he's
[ __ ] nuts
and he's just making all like these loud
[ __ ] and sounds like brah Oh
- this exposure would turns a light on
bro and like shines it on the ship which
I thought was way that is when you know
somebody [ __ ] right and then he's like
are you sober and I was like yeah man
I'm sober he's like you're sober and
you're sitting here watching your friend
[ __ ] in a tunnel which I thought was
pretty funny a good point on his part
he's like if you're sober you got a
drive dude you know and that was it I
got the driver's seat and drove us out
of there while he [ __ ] in the back yeah
I've had a lot of weird times in
Pittsburgh and it's a wild city dude why
do you spend so much time because one of
my best friends over there actually the
guy was [ __ ] in that frisbees that's
friends and uh and he live there and I
just like it dude how pink are their
once got a [ __ ] behind the giant
eagle which I gotta tell you you
probably got that frisbee is that a
great time I've always wanted to go to
oh it's still game there's not a bad
seat announcement it's awesome yeah
people that can't even read they can say
Steelers and cheer for them can't read
can't even see blind people yes yelling
Steelers and they're not even at the
games
just [ __ ] scam them sold my ticket
yeah something just playing like an old
game with some like on a radio I was
going on there but a great city man have
you been like every city in the country
you think I think so man all the coasts
have a minute was Alaska at this point
in New Hampshire
nobody New Hampshire boys what are you
gonna get there's a good Tuesday night
show there yeah Mandy Vegas well twos
these riders do yeah another crappy sing
it yeah I'll be not been there you've
been in Vermont yeah I think I better
run how'd you get her how'd you get all
up the New England without going through
New Hampshire's went around this [ __ ] I
don't know yeah this way you know flew
out to some place or something did
something like that you know the doing
gigs you know whatever yeah I've done a
gig in Alaska have you I'm yeah no way a
lot yeah oh wow Freddie's awesome yeah
what was that like it was a trip man
that place is a total trip there like
everyone treats you like they know you
guy took us up an assassin ax oh wow we
went to a modeling hockey game in the
Cessna Freddie grew up like on military
bases so didn't the frisbee in the back
comfy man up there in the system and
they only had headsets for two so
Freddie had a headset and the guy had a
headset I didn't have a headset and
Freddie grew up you know in this kind of
environment next thing I know this guys
doing zero-gravity dives you haven't
done that you go up and he's drunk the
plane and they throw the pencil up in
the air to float and I know was going on
all sides so they're dying a frog they
think it's the greatest then we watched
some chicks snort oxycotin off a table
and the in the plane now after our show
she ha turn up in the cockpit
she's like check well I got a I got a
drive my friend so they got a kid at
home and she's like hold on and she's
crushing up this thing and I'm like oh
she's crushing up candy we had smoked a
little and then Freddie goes is that
Coke and she's like no and I was like
good I just didn't want this chick doing
coke before she drives em home she was
its oxycontin
I mean it was a trip God get my friend's
home safe to have kids
yeah man somebody's got to take care of
these yeah yeah sounds awesome
man yeah I mean you gotta go mean I
would just go for a silly game I mean
it's great you'll get the whole thing
everybody's wants you to eat a big
sandwich and [ __ ] bang their chubby
sister you know a lot of [ __ ] said a
lot of huge foreheads before yes for hey
country your polish yeah man I pull this
Nicaraguan dude where my poles at huh
we're my Nik gars they call Nicaraguans
yeah I I got in trouble one time out
here when I first moved here because
there's a great I'm not a big hot dog
guy all right not really but there's a
spot I'm not I'm not pizza oh yeah I
like hot dogs not big but there's a
joint in Baltimore it's still there it's
called Pollock Johnny's mm-hmm so I was
when I first got here I had a job in
like an office as a PA and I was like
all this hot dog plays back or call Pole
like that they were like whoa whoa whoa
whoa and I was like what they're like
you can't that's offensive you can't say
I'm like that's the name of the that's
like the actual name of the restaurant
and I had to look it up and show him
there I don't say that [ __ ] anymore I'm
like it's [ __ ] restaurant like Johnny
dude they had IRA were growing up at a
kid and one of our classes named Thomas
[ __ ] Minh was his last name good lord
yeah Oman and I'm like that's we chained
enough way to go man yeah with 3 R's
that was a crazy part I remember Thomas
a [ __ ] Minh 3r yeah they really
stressed that [ __ ] I suppose the rolling
Nicaragua yeah I mean no he wasn't
Nicaraguan he was he was why he was
ginger actually he was ginger like it's
a it's a class it's a subspecies no
offensive you guys are gingers so but
yeah man so that's [ __ ] I mean that's
that was where I was from him we went
back there we shot the special and uh
and it was good man I'm excited about it
and when's it come out February
all right gank or maybe March it says
spring yeah so I mean it's just good
like you guys know it's good also it you
know get
something done make a CD or you know and
I you know the corner album anything
they kind of put something away you can
kind of think about the next chapter
you're like because we can get caught
just milling around you know no [ __ ]
wondering like you know what's gonna be
next am i'd you do i make the next thing
or you know what's gonna happen don't
want if i can get a job at fedex you
know like but you don't think about this
thing to you to close off something else
you know where UPS guys actually home
row problem i want to happen to play
what else is on there is there a couple
other ones on there yeah dick pics i
wanted to ask you about dick pics right
below [ __ ] in a frisbee well we're
heading in a positive direction I uh I'm
in this crazy thread with some guys from
the Comedy Store right and Jason Tebow
is one of the guys comedian
Jason go learned Earl Skakel Adam Egan
EJ I'm not sure he says I said egg it
may be edge I don't know but um so some
of the guys send dick pics out all the
time right like we're on this thread
basically we're like we're all [ __ ]
like everybody has said things on there
and like put out D pics were like it's
not safe for anybody right like yeah
like you I think it's not like somebody
has to kill everyone else like it's good
right but one of the guys keeps putting
up some D pics right and I'm my DN on
there right but I started talking to
this girl and she wanted to see some
dick pics and I'm like I want to have
any you know but I want to be like ass
or you know a sore loser I guess or so
sort of sport sort of be a bad sport
so I started sending his dick pics he's
only put two up so now it's weird cuz
I'm like trying to entice another dick
pic out of them without asking for it
directly because every other dick that's
been blasted into this thread has been
you know just that people so are like
hey look at this dick ah you know not
like hey let me see your dick and then
someone shares it you know that's gay
like do ya you don't want to ask for
yeah so it's weird cuz this girl now has
two dick pics of someone's a third and
it's like I can't get him pics back oh
yeah oh yeah you gotta put something up
yeah and I can't sound like a different
dick now like it's you know cuz I've
looked at a couple online and they're
different yeah there's these dicks are
definitely missing any images or some
it's dark it's a dark underworld in
these texts why wouldn't you just
shooter your own dick cuz I want to do
that and like sometimes my dick look
like it my dick doesn't hold like carry
light very well-trained hasn't been a
class or anything it just looks so
amateur you know it's like a beleaguered
echo the stick maybe plays doubles like
pistol pee would seem like [ __ ] Lee
Harvey do you know
oh right there man out we're about out
of time that's all right this has been
there's been a lot of fun we knew it
would be that everything on the list
yeah and then some I even added wooden
shirt yeah what happened to him Nathan
do you have a lot of people from like
growing up hit you up on Facebook and
stuff outside of like old family members
you don't know about some us to argue
with you know a lot of people my
neighborhood have died or in jail
actually can that actual neighborhood
but if some of the kids got out of there
so you're the one who got out being a
couple of the guys Timmy uh no Timmy's
on hilari what was there no there was
another kid named Larry though he had a
really really special birthmark and uh
yeah but you're look at Malcolm X on him
but his family was real racist so they
didn't they thought it was like a sign
you know that's is this for real
yeah that it wasn't good you know but uh
Jesus Christ but no man they saw the kid
named Robby from my town who started a
really good business and then uh
another kid named Gerald he started his
own business but uh fun neighborhood
just you keep in touch with those guys
yep I keep in touch with some of them
now now we've gotten older and away from
that environment cuz it was hectic any
um come your special any of those yeah
that was pretty cool that is cool so I'm
gonna start to work on another hour now
hopefully about that neighborhood you
know oh my god zero and enemy you know
yeah I just got a just got to try and
figure it out a little bit better but
well why don't you one more time tell
everybody about your special where they
can see all that stuff again Theo von
man th EO vo in you can check it out on
Netflix in the spring and you're gonna
tweet it out anyway I'll tweet it out
man and I'll tweet out this episode and
uh and I'll be at laughs Boston the
weekend before Christmas so come check
me out there Friday and Saturday night
the 18th and 19th and then in January
where January I'll be at the Pittsburgh
improv six through the tenth go see Theo
von
let's get pinkeye dog [ __ ] in the
frisbee dude and hopefully you guys are
back on the crab feast I mean Jesus
Christ and if you've you ever seen Theo
stand-up one of our favorites no
question early me too but you guys same
as me man same same same bro I think
we're all kind of in the same thread
yeah you might not be no he's more
smarter yeah you're in the I don't have
three degrees thanks for coming on thank
you so much Jay Larson call me calm Jay
Larson comedy on all social media Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Facebook
Ryan psycho calm we'll talk to you all
next hey [ __ ] the crab feast son 5 stars
5 stars